We’re following a member of a private and
controversial border watch organization “Minute
Men”.
Robert Crooks, a 67-year old retiree from
Las Vegas patrols the US-Mexican border in
the Campo area,north of San Diego.
Crooks has been doing this for about a month
now…
every day.
He lives and sleeps in his pick-up truck – AND
he patrols, watches, and tracks, what he calls
invaders and enemies of the United States
of America.
“They are not coming this way.
And if the do I'll be waiting for them watching.
They’re not sneaking in.”
Roberts joined the “Minute Men Project”
- a group that many describe as a dangerous
militia - in 2005.
He says, even back then he felt he needed
to help secure the border and fight off what
he calls an invasion of illegal immigrants.
“It’s my country, it’s your country,
it’s our country.
You know, if nobody makes a stand, we wouldn’t
have a country.”
He sees himself as a patriot.
He claimed this hilltop overseeing the border
for himself by installing a flag pole.
This is his base.
He named it “Point Patriot”.
It is here where - in his view - he serves
his country at a critical time.
Where he makes a stand in what he calls the
epic battle against illegal immigrants.
“This is a defining moment in history right
now.
If we don't do something here today, this,
you know right now, this could be, it's got
the ramifications of turning into something
very dangerous to our nation.
If we start allowing hoards of thousands and
thousands just to cross the border, crush
our cities you know, that's a recipe for disaster
you know.
It has to stop here.”
For all of the “criminals in Tijuana”,
as he calls the Caravan migrants from Central
America sheltered on the other side of the
border, Robert has this message:
“They have to go back home.
…America is full.”
The Federal Agents of the US Border Patrol
do NOT necessarily agree with any of Crook’s
sentiments.
However, out here in the field they do appreciate
him patrolling the area, watching and alerting
them to suspicious movements from the other
side.
That’s enough of a reward for this Minute
man.
“As long as this is going on, I will be
involved.”